日本で家を買うとは思ってもみませんでした
古い日本の家は美しいですが
、夏は暑
すぎて冬は寒すぎて、
本当に安全に生活できるようになるまでには、通常、大量の改修が必要です
ほとんどの近代的な工場で建てられた日本の
家屋は、正反対のようなもので、
非常に機能的です
が、古い日本の家屋の伝統的な日本建築の魂と暖かさが欠けており、
実際には3番目の選択肢はありません。
少なくとも
約 14 か月前までは、妻
がシーナリー ハウスという地元の小さな住宅会社を発見し、
一緒に建てたのは単なる家ではなく
、南日本のオフィス兼ゲストルームだと思っていました。
他の YouTube 仲間と私の twitch の
友達が
出てきて、彼らがその場所に来て
、リラックスして、自分のビデオを作ることができる
ことを知っています。 これは
私にとって大きなリスクです。大きなギャンブル
のようなものですが
、シーナリーハウスのチームが作って
いるような空間を見たとき、私はプレートにステップアップして
自分の快適ゾーンから出て
道を譲らなければならないと感じました. 彼らが本当に特別なものを作ることができるように予算を超えて
おり、
私は家にそれ自体を語らせるだけなので、少し後悔していません
.tokyo lensのnormとmanuに感謝したい.
私たちがコラボレーションしたばかりの新しいチャンネルを立ち上げる私の YouTube 仲間の 2 人に
、このビデオに参加して助けてくれたことに
感謝したいと思い
ます。 皆さんのサポートがなければ、これは
不可能
でした。皆さんのサポートのおかげで、
本当に特別なものを作ることができたと
思います。皆さんにもう一度感謝します。
ほとんどの人はただ見たいと思っていると思い
ます。 家だけど
話すのやめよう これで家のツアーを開始でき
ます
ので、これ
は dogen と norm と manu です。
ついに私の家の内部に到達し
ました。
オーケー、目を開けていいよ
[音楽]
だから今、私たちは
自然に渡り板の中にい
ますが、
クールなことの1つは、
これがゲストギャングガンであることです。
ここを通り抜ける
ときれいだし、汚れた靴などをすべて見る必要はない
ので、入り口が 2 つあり、これ
が家族の
靴のクローゼットです
[音楽
] 正直言って、秘密の部屋があるようです
私が家を建てたら
秘密の通路が欲しいといつも思っ
ていましたあなたはそのようなものを持っていますええ、私たちは
今ここに歩いて行くことができますが、通常
私たちはここにいますあなたは今立っ
ていますコートの髪のようなものがあります ラック
今はまだ
右上にある そうギャングガンみたいな土間みたいな
実際 2 階は石の
床
で、雨の日のように
ここにコートを掛けることができ
ます。おそらく最初にこれを見たのではないでしょう
か。
広い土地で
安い理由は景色が
ないからだと思いますが、家に囲まれているので何か素晴らしい景色が見えるようにしてほしいと思います。
家
の真ん中に自然を入れてみましょう。
彼らは中庭の
右側にある家のこのセクションの周りに家を建てました。
これは寝室のようなもので
、これは
右側のリビングエリアの残りの部分のようなものです
。 このエリアは最初に
チェックアウトしていただきありがとうございます
とてもクールです
いいえ、作業エリアのようなものです ええ、
とてもクールです ここは私の娘の部屋です ここは私の
娘の部屋
です。
out to you
すぐに気付くだろうけど
このように部屋を分割すると、完全に
対称になります。将来的には完全に対称になります。
私の娘たちがより多くのプライバシーを求めたときに、
ここに別の壁を作り
、それぞれに自分の
部屋
を用意し、これらのドアがそこから出てくるようにします。
側面はええ
[音楽]
ここは服のようなもので、誰も
が自分のドアを
持っています。なぜなら、この部屋を2つに分割すると、2つの
小さな小さな部屋の
ようにわずかに半分になるからです。
部屋から出て廊下に出て勉強するのに使うだろう
廊下の全長に渡ってこの巨大な机があり、
自然に彼らは
勉強の本やそのようなものを
将来的に置くことができます ここのキッチンは
道の真向かいにあります ええ、あなたは私の妻
が夕食の準備ができていることを知っている
か、何
でも知っているように知ってい
ます 家の小さな詳細
私が思うすべては
ここの後ろからの光源のように本当にクールだと
思います ええと呼ばれていることに気づいて
うれしい 私たちは
ええ、私の寝室に行くことができ
ます ありがとう
[音楽]
それは素晴らしい
です
それと一緒に行くには、はるかに
高価なオプション
でしたが、ええと
、このようなビデオをもっと作ることで将来的に報われることを望んでいます。
ええと
、夏にはセントラルエアコンがあり、
冷たい空気が
そこから降りてきます。 冬は
熱気が下から上がってくる
ので、ここ10年半ほど日本にいることも言及する価値があると思います。
これは私が今まで見た中で3番目の
家であり、中心的な生活を送っています。
そうではありません。 アーチが持つ一般的なものの 1 つ
itectが言ったのは
、この
種のような大きなマシン
が個々の部屋のように見えなくなったという事実のようなもの
です.彼はそれが大きな違いを生むだろう
と言っています.私は彼に完全に同意し
ます.
日本の家とか、本当に
美しい部屋のように、エアコン
はたいてい、ちょっと目立っているものの 1 つ
です。 今の
ところロールスクリーンがあります
ので、この家には
カーテンがありません.
最初の4つの
素晴らしい日本のトイレ
をチェックできるかもしれません.それはあなたがよく知っている基本的なものです.
基本的な日本のトイレでさえ、アメリカに戻った
ようなものに比べて通常はかなりいいということです
が、ええと
、皆さんはちょっとチェックして
みて
ください。植物の細部が好きだと思います
が、 それは
住宅会社であり、将来は存在しない可能性があり
ます.すべての忍者のものは
私が
愛しているもの
です.ああ、
わかりました. 家の家族のキッチンエリア
これは私がこれまで
の人生で見た中で最も素敵なキッチンです文字通り
そう
ですこれはテレビのキッチンのようなものですあなたは
これを正しく保つことができますはい
これまでで最高の
質問です
おそらく無意識のうちに
どこ
にあるのでしょう 料理をしている時のキッチンフードのようなものです 煙はどこに行ったの
ですか それはそれ
です
私の妻は彼女がよく料理をすることについてかなり頑固でした 私は彼女が
料理をしません
あなたが知っているように建築家に尋ねました
通常、キッチンのキッチンには
これらのような低いフードがあり
、それが必要であることは理解してい
ますが、
この低いキッチンハウスを使わずに換気システムを作成する方法はあり
ますか?
木と野菜の しかし、
彼らがやったことは
ここの通気口の後ろ
にあり、実際にはその中には強力なファンのようなものがあり
、そのエリアを吸い込み、
ここから上がってくるすべての空気が
家の冷蔵庫の外に押し出されます
ここに行きます
自然に自然
に彼らは本当に知っているよう
です
必要以上に大きくしない
でください ええ、これはあなたの冷蔵庫のサイズのよう
です
わかりました そのサイズで作業します
ああ、隠しドア
がたくさんあるので、これは私の
妻のキッチュまたはパントリー
ですので
、おそらく家で私のお気に入りの点は何かをお話しします。
それはこの窓です。フレーム自体だけではありません。 木材ですが、
この木材
[音楽] を作る
ことは、ここのこのエリアのように、ここには
アルミニウムのようなものがないということも意味し
ます。あなたが知っているのは、
ええ、木材です。
もう一度キッチンに来て
、キッチンから外を見てみると、 これ
は開いているので、 ええと、真ん中の柱がなくなったことを知っています。
この大きく開いたようなものはとてもクールです。ほとんど絵画のようです。これを大きく開くこと
ができます。
家は
周りに建てられているので、侵入する風を心配する必要はありません。
または、強い風など、
この穏やかな気持ちになるものは何でもいい言葉で表現することはできません。
また、本当に素敵に見えるの
は、お母さんの緑と黒の
ようなものです。 秋には色がよく変わります
はい はい それは
おそらく本当に素晴らしいですね 日本は
夏の間非常に暑い
ので
、入ってくる日光を遮断したい時があります
そうです そう
です それは巨大な窓でした
そこにはカーテンがありますが、
ここにはカーテンレールはありません。家
の広い範囲に日光を遮断したい場合は、カーテンではなく、
これらが組み込まれています
[音楽]
ええと、おそらくこれから入手するのが良いでしょう
Y側
ええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ ええ
建築家が主張したのではなく、
私はカーテンを使用しないと言った
ので、代わりに
この伝統的な日本の伝統的な日本の
紙のドアを使用します。
これはズッキーニとして知られているもので
、
冬に雪が降った
場合、外の味のようなものを知ることができます。
外には雪
がありますが、 プライバシーのためのこの種のように
、まさに
そのシナリオを維持することができます。
私はまた、多くの光をあふれさせるように、これらの窓が
好き
です。これは、あなたが知っているかどうかの別の例です。
そして、これはええと
ソファです
[音楽]
それは組み込まれています 素敵な妻と私は
どちらもコーヒーが大好き
で
、テーブルが正しく使用されていない場合、テーブルは必要ないというように、前に話していたようなものだと思いました。
これ
は
とてもクールなカップホルダーです
ので、
コーヒー
をここに置いたのはご存知でしょう。これも
換気の一部です。または、それ
は本当に良いキャッチな
ので、熱い空気がソファの下から来て
、あなたは' 皆さんはこれを
気に入るはずですが、ここにLANポートがある特定の理由は、私が
YouTuberであり、将来、家の
さまざまな場所からライブストリームを行うことを計画
し
ているためです。 有線接続
で、これは家の中で本当に
見栄えの良い部分です。ここの
このソファでインタビューを行うのは素晴らしい
ことです。ライブストリームを知っていることもあり
ますが、twitchや
あなたが言及した実際の面白いことは何でも知っています。
好きだから この
種の配色はまた
、あなたのスタジオのセットアップを思い出させます。
ええ、ええ、そうです、青
とすべてがセーターのようなもの
です。 今のところ
、この方向を見てみてください。下を向かないようにし
て
ください。実際には
、こちらのように見えます。
これは明らかに、洗濯機が移動するエリアを知っています。
洗濯機はここにあります。
そして、
あなたは私たちが以前にそれを見たときにこれについて考えていませんでし
た
が、
私が今それを指摘すると、ああ、それが本当であることに気付くでしょう.
私の部屋の女の子の部屋にはクローゼットがありませんでした。
その理由は
家族のクローゼットは 1 つしかないので oh wow
[Music]
うーん、4 人が
いて、家には他にクローゼットはありません。これは
意図的な設計上の決定
です。 ウォーキング
家の反対側まで
ずっとこれについて考えたことはありませんでしたが、
正直
なところ、夜にシャワーを浴びた後、
またはほとんどの
変更が
ランドリールームまたはバスルームの中または近くで行われ
ます.
私はベッドルームで実際に着替えたことはほとんどあり
ませんええ、私は考えたことが
ないくらい何回あなたが好きです
かあなたはあなたの下着が好きで
、Tシャツが好きで
、次にシンクのように着ます
裸で家の中を歩くのではなく、バスルームに行き
ましょう ここに別のドアが
あり、これを閉めることができ
、更衣室を使用する必要があるとき
にクローゼットを使用できます
やめてください、これは懸垂です。以前は武道のトリックに夢中だったと主張していました。懸垂とワークアウトを行うのが本当に好き
ですが、これらの機器のいずれかを購入しない限り
、部屋の半分を占める機器です。ええ それから
現代の日本の家のようにプルアップを行うのは本当に
難しいです.日本のドアフレーム
は、それらが正確
に壊れるよう
に作られていないためです. というのは、それ
は
まさに日本の
[音楽]
のハンガーのようなディスプレイのようなものだと思うからです。その結果
、温泉付きの高価な家があるかどうかに関係なく、別府には多くの家があり
、私たちにも温泉があります。 私たちは神々しく離れようとしているような気が
するので、ここ
に行き
ます
ああ、ああ、なんてこった、
そこには庭のある専用の小さな窓があります。
あなたが言ったことの中で、ああ
、あなたの寝室は包まれて
いません。接続されていません。
その理由は、温泉には
腐食する可能性のある素材があるからです。ええ、
この壁の後ろには防水加工が施されていて、それ
がずっと伸びています。
そこら辺ですぅ ch 温泉を使っ
ていても寝室には湿気が入らない
ええ まさに
それが第2の湿気だからだと思い
ます でも実際にここに来て座っ
てください 大きな切り欠きがあります あなたが見ることができる あそこの
空から ああ、私は本当に
奇妙な場所への執着を持って
います 素敵な温泉のようなものです うーん、リラックスしたり、抱きしめたりするの
が好きな素敵な景色があります
ええ、これ
はとても素敵です
後でお勧めします。
私が世界中のシャワーで抱えている最大の問題の 1 つ
は
、シャワー ヘッドが常に非常に
小さいことです。常に
動き回って
、ここでは問題のない位置を見つける必要があります。
これを見てください
[音楽]
はい、私はクールな人で背の高い人
です。これ
が日本の
シャワーの標準的な身長だとし
たら、あなたは本当にいいマイクを持っています。
ええ、
それはばかげた質問でした。 私はどのようによく言った
建築物の木に水をやるつもりですか シャワーを使って
ください ええええ それで道元は私の部屋を見ることができ
ます はい
ところで私は
東京に住んでい
ないユーチューバーとして引っ越します お二人とも東京に住んでいて
君たちと動画を作りたいけど、僕は
ずっと東京に飛べないし、
君たちはホテルが高いからずっと寝てられないから、
本当は
ゲストルームが欲しかったんだ
[音楽]
よし
[
これ
は素敵なゲストルームです。
ここに
ある理由は
、ゲストが
夜更かしを
したり、ラップトップのスピーカーのように使用
したり、 彼らは私たちを
起こすかどうかにかかわらず、別のバスルームがある
ので、あなたたちが来るときはとてもクール
で、起きていたいと思ってい
ます。夜にビデオを編集し
、バスルームを使用する必要があります ここ
で起こっていることを聞く方法はありませ
ん。あちら側からのようです。 それは
起きていて、この大きなオープン
エリアのように向かい合っているので、ええ、実際にはええ、
神聖な大きなクローゼットです。
そこには余分なゲストを全員入れることができます。ええ
、2人が来たい場合に備えて、少なくとも2人用のスペースが必要でした。
時間ええスペースまたはカメラ
ギアバックパックなどのよう
なものであり、それが目的であり、
ここにもプラグがあり
ます。バッテリーを充電できますカメラを充電します。
子供たちがここで遊んでいるなら、
彼らはあなたが知っていることを
知っているので、あなたは彼らとナーフをプレイ
し、ええ
、高台を取るだけで、視聴者のよう
なミステリーを構築する必要があります。
そして
、あなたがちょっとええと推測したとは信じられないようなものです.
実際の
皇居はそこにあります.
これは私たちが以前に来た靴のクローゼットであり、
それ
は参照フレームの一種のためのキッチンエリアです.
そして、これはちょっとした
追加のストレージです
ああ、そのスペースはすでにとてもクール
です。私たちは今、これは将校
としてかなり楽しいものになるでしょう。
はい、
建築家が私がとても
興味深いと思ったことの1つはあなたです. 在宅
勤務ですが、在宅勤務について私たちがよく話してき
たことは
、あなたが住んでいる場所で働くとき、睡眠を大幅に削減することです。
作業
モード
とリラクゼーションモード、または非作業モードを区別するのは非常に難しい
ということです。 ええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ
大丈夫です 仕事をやめたばかりです
が、同じ椅子に座っ
てネットフリックスを見ているだけです ええ、私は働いています
か、それとも私は父親のように、
家族の時間は必要ないかどうかを判断する必要があります
オフィス
[音楽] おやおやおやおやおやおやおやおやおやおや、
あなたが説明したよりもはるかに良く見えます
ねおお、私
たちが
非常に初期の段階にい
たとき、あなたは素晴らしいことを説明するのが下手ですね、彼はあなたが現在自分のオフィスで自宅で仕事をしていると言いまし
た 変更できるとしたら最も難しいことの 1 つは
、あなたならどうしますか
。部屋で撮影すると、部屋
が三脚の森になり始めるので、2 人ともこれを高く評価
できると私は言いました。はい、私は彼に尋ねました。
照明システムをセットアップして、
十分な光を得ることができ、現在
私のオフィスにあるこの巨大な三脚を設置する必要がないときに、物事を変更するのに十分な柔軟性を好む方法
. 私ができることを見てください.
ええと
、彼が最終的に何をしたかは、あなたがここに見ているものです.ほとんど
の場合、天井を横切るこれらのライトレールがあります.
これらはそうではありません.
そう見えるだけ
これだけでも良いのですが、
天井が
完全に平らではなくこのようになっている理由は、
これが実際にどれだけ機能しているかはわかりませ
んが、どうやら
箱のように
箱の部屋がもっとたくさん反響し
ます。 これにより、エコーがはるかに少なくなり
ます。気にしない場合は、ええええ、このようにするか、この
ようにするかを判断できます。ええと
、
ええ、そして
この後ろに私の机がある場所です。
巣はええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ
ええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ コマンドセンターのようなキッチンエリア
あなたがそこにいれば、私が何を意味するか知ってい
ます家の子供たちに全員を誘導することができます
はい行きましょう私が何を意味するかを理解してください
ええええええここは
あなた自身を呼び出すことができる素晴らしいスペース
です 私たちの反応は
すべてですが、ええ、あなたはどのようにあなたが好きです
か、それについてどのように感じますか 私は
言葉を超えて喜んでいます 私はこの
家
をあなたや他の友人のような人々のためのクールなスペースにしようとしてい
ます あなたは私たちの他の仲間を知っています
クリス・ジョーイ・コナー などなど
、彼らが来て歓迎を感じることができる場所で
あり、私たちはあなたが冷静になり、一緒にビデオを作ることができます.
それはドーガンの家
だけではありません.
私はこの建築家と仕事をすることができてとても光栄に感じ
ました.この機会が与えられたら.
自分の限界を超えて自分を追い込みたいと思っている
し、自分の手の届かないものを作ることも知って
いますここに立っているクリエイターとして、
あなたが何かを作りたいと思っているように感じます。
私は好きです ここで撮影できます あっちで撮影できます
はい、私は日本の伝統建築の大ファンです
私たちは
これについて伝統的な日本の
建築によく似ていますが、多くの
欠点がありますが、それ
を多くの現代建築と組み合わせます 要素 私は
ここ
でやっ
た ええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ
匂いがわからなくて、私
だけに触れ
てほしいです私は彼らに触れ続けているので、犬は私に腹を立て続けてい
ます。
古い日本の
家や寺院のような
ものには、エンゲージと呼ばれるものがあり
ます。これは本質的に私たちが今取り組んでいるものです。窓に沿って
伸びる長い
ポーチの
ようなものです。 持っているおばあさん
ここにお茶
を置いたり、あなたが知っているものは何でもここに置く予定
の小さなテーブルのように、
あなたがデッキセットを知っているように、
他に言うことは何もありません。
とても平和で、
まるでコミカル
に静かな場所のようです
[音楽]
だから、それがみんなの場所
です。
家に関連するパイプラインのビデオは
他にもありますが
、建築プロセス
、材料、すべてまたは
部品のコストなどについて質問がある人もいると思います。
これらの質問は下に残してください。
「別のビデオでそれらすべてに答えようとします。
また、家で
のノルムとモリーナのビデオもチェックしてください。また
、この種のコンテンツを作成するのはどちら
も私よりも優れています。どちらも
信じられないほどのクリエーターです。  ators ですから、
以下にリンクされているチャンネルとビデオをチェックすることをお勧め
し
ます。皆さんの継続的なサポートに改めて感謝します。またすぐにお会いし
ましょう